kubernetes is helping developer and
operations teams deploy more complex
applications than ever when rolling out
a new release or making other changes to
our production services we need to make
sure we're prepared for any issues
stackdriver is Google's fully featured
operations management suite for cloud
powered applications let's take a look
at how it can help you keep your
applications and services healthy this
is the stack doctor as you might have
heard the stack driver team has been
working hard to support using stack
driver with kubernetes it's still in
beta but I'm here today to give you a
sneak peek the first and obvious thing
we need the kubernetes cluster to
monitor let's create one and there's no
better or easier place to do that than
google kubernetes engine or gke now the
beta feature is only available for
clusters running kubernetes version 1 10
6 or later so let's create one of those
here's the G cloud command we're gonna
use to create our cluster note the
enable stackdriver kubernetes flag that
opts us into the beta monitoring and
logging features we also need the
cluster version latest flag to make sure
there weren't a supported version at
least one 10 six once the cluster is up
and running we'll want to see exactly
what's running there and what better way
to do that than with cube CTL we have
the monitoring and logging agents the
metadata agent and heaps are all running
in a stack driver agent namespace these
will collect all the details we need
from our nodes running in the cluster
now that we have a cluster with
monitoring setup on it let's take a look
at the data when we go to stack driver
by clicking on monitoring from the
products and services menu and look at
the resources menu we can see a new
entry called kubernetes beta this is the
Nuclear Nettie's monitoring UI let's
take a look the first thing you'll
notice is that we have three different
ways of looking at our cluster the
infrastructure of you may be more useful
for understanding the physical layout of
your cluster nodes and what's running
where the workloads view is more
relevant if you care about what's
running in the cluster in namespaces
more so than about the nodes this may be
relevant for folks responsible for the
applications and services such as the
DevOps teams and finally the services of
you can help you understand how
workloads in the cluster are exposed as
services load balancers ingress
controllers and the like and this might
be most relevant if you're attempting to
troubleshoot an issue attempting to
communicate with the services running on
the cluster and don't necessarily need
to know about
what's behind the services themselves
note that every view allows you to click
on any of the elements to get more
details about them you can see things
like open incidents affecting that
particular component other events such
as container restarts and performance
and utilization metrics even logs are
integrated into this view for easy
access now there are clusters up and
monitoring is in place we can use
stackdriver to insure their application
stays healthy come back next time when
we use stackdriver to identify triage
and diagnose problems on our application
that's it for this episode this is a
stack doctor stay healthy out there